il y a maintenant une mémoire collective
des émeutes dans beaucoup de banlieu et
en particulier des banlieux des plus
grandes métropole française c'est pas
simplement 2005 c'est une succession
d'événements qui marque la la la la vie
locale qui et qui marque aussi les
expériences politiques des des des des
personnes qui participent de près ou de
loin à ces émeutes et qu'il y a là me
semble-t-il une différence très forte
entre cette mémoire collective qui
devient très structurante dans les
banlieu des grandes métropoes versus la
la la faible présence de cette mémoire
collective dans les petites villes les
villes moyennes dont je vous ai parlé et
je vous reparlerai du lien avec les
gilets jaunes après donc qu'est-ce qui
se passe c'est-à-dire que il faut bien
voir que cette cette mémoire elle est
aussi portée par et là je relativiste
qui a été dit précédemment par le fait
que dans si on regarde sur plusieurs
décennies il y a dans dans C dans ces
quartiers c'està-dire les quartiers en
difficulté des grandes banlieues des
métropole il y a un tissu associatif qui
a une longue histoire maintenant et qui
et qui s'est renouvelé et qui porte
aujourd'hui à juste titre pas ce titre
un discours très fort de lutte contre
les discriminations et donc le fait
aussi que dans ces quartiers là un tissu
associatif se mobilise essaie de de de
de donner une forme à ses revendications
et à une sorte de conscience de
l'intensité de certaines discriminations
ça participe aussi des dynamiques
émeutières dans la région parisienne
c'est pas le cas dans les petites villes
et villes moyennes je ne dis pas que
dans les quartiers les plus paupérisés
de ces petites villes et villes moyenne
il n'y a pas de tissu associatif qui
porte une sorte de conscience du point
de vue de la lutte contre les
discriminations mais il est beaucoup
moins fort et lriue beaucoup moins ces
quartiers que dans les les les quartiers
prioritaires de la politique de la ville
des grandes métropoles